police in france have arrested a second
suspect in connection with a knife
attack at the basilica in nice that left
three people dead it was the third
islamist attack in france
in two months president emmanuel macron
is holding an emergency cabinet meeting
today
the terror alert level is now at its
maximum
a place of worship and the scene of
terror
candles laid outside the notre dame
church in nice
a tribute for the victims killed within
its walls
what happened inside is now being pieced
together by forensics teams
france's top anti-terrorism prosecutor
said this had all the hallmarks of a
terrorist attack
and they have detained a suspect
when he was arrested he was carrying a
document
in the form of a paper from the italian
red cross in the name of a tunisian
national born
in 1999.
initial investigations have shown that
this is the perpetrator
moreover the person concerned is not
known
in the national fingerprint database and
is not known to the intelligence
services
when the police stormed the church on
thursday it was too late to stop the
bloodshed
a church official and woman had been
stabbed and killed
a third person died of her injuries
police found a copy of the quran and
three large knives in the suspect's bags
the man is now in hospital in critical
condition
president macron was at the scene within
hours
calling for national unity
if we've been attacked again it's
because of our values
our belief in freedom to believe freely
and not give
the french president has angered many in
the muslim world
by refusing to condemn cartoons of the
prophet muhammed
[Applause]
it's a long-standing debate in france
reignited by the murder of school
teacher samuel patti
earlier this month he was beheaded after
showing cartoons of muhammad
in a class on free speech and with this
latest attack
france has three more people to mourn
well for the very latest on that story
we're now joined by correspondent lisa
lewis in news lisa there's been a new
arrest in this case what can you tell us
about that
well police just confirmed me that they
indeed
arrested a 47 year old man apparently
that man
was living in the region around nice
and he is originally from a maghrib
country now he was on the phone with the
attacker
several times the day before the attack
so two days ago
and the police are now looking into the
question if
he was just in touch or if he was an
accomplice
of the murderer the the assailant who
killed three people
at the cathedral just behind me if
france is at its highest
terror alert level what does that
actually mean
well it means that an additional 4 000
soldiers and police forces are deployed
across the country at them
are being deployed across the country at
the moment to protect
vulnerable locations here in france
the police told me that they considered
that
under the lockdown because france has
now entered a lockdown for
probably at least four weeks under the
lockdown
vulnerable places are not only places of
worship and those
locations where terror attacks happened
in the past
but also public transport because under
the lockdown that's where people are
crowded really
so the polices really are really on high
alert and they're trying to protect as
many places as they can at the moment
well today lisa france is going into
lockdown um how will that affect the
both the um the public commemoration
uh of these latest killings and and also
the investigation
well obviously you know public
commemorations will be difficult to
carry out if you look back a few weeks
you know when samuel patti was beheaded
by a
a radical islamist the teacher who had
shown a cartoon of the prophet of
muhammad
in his classroom after that president
he indeed held a public ceremony to
commemorate
this man but this will hardly be
possible now here in france under
lockdown there might be some online
event or something or
email mccomb might hold a public speech
on television
but you can't obviously gather people
here in france at the moment
and the police are saying that they
are expecting to stay people at home and
but as i said they will still be on high
alert and there will still be
a a terror attack alert a terror alert
here in france they're
going to try to protect these places
that are vulnerable here in france
i'll correspond at lisa lewis in nice
thank you lisa
well there has been reaction to these uh
killings all over europe but also here
in germany
the germany's president frankfurter
steinmeier spoke to dw about the attack
of course our thoughts are above all
with the relatives
who have our compassion but i believe
what we in europe and not just in france
must do now
is to stand up to this act of brutality
and the islamist motives behind it
in our democratic societies above all we
should not base the response of the
state
on a course determined by hate and
xenophobia
acceptance and mutual respect are a part
of our society
and so standing up to such acts of
brutal violence and
islamist motives is one thing the other
is to try and maintain the openness of
our society
that's the other challenge so let's get
the security perspective now with dian
son pierre counter terrorism advisor and
ceo of
security provider mosicon here in berlin
thanks so much for coming in on this
today john
when you look at the attack in nice was
this
a sole perpetrator or do you think a
larger network
was involved in this attack
well what we've seen recently whether
it's the attack two weeks ago
or the one in mid-september is that uh
even if the
the attacker perpetrated the attack
alone there's always a
a certain there's always a form of
support whether it's financial whether
it's
ideological uh online or offline so
that i think is the main question for
for this attack considering that he
apparently arrived
in france only a few days ago um you
know
did they get support out of tunisia did
he have any support in italy
that'll be important but what we've seen
certainly in recent cases is that
even if the actor does look to have
acted alone in fact there is a certain
degree of support
online or offline and it could be
international
as you're indicating why is france
seeing
so many islamist terror attacks right
now three over the last two months
well the the overall polarized situation
in france
beginning with the the trial around
charlie abdul the republication of the
caricatures
mid-september uh macon's reactions
uh to to these caricatures uh there
there's
within the muslim community there's some
that are denouncing this but in
extremist circles this is used again as
proof that france must be targeted the
calls for
attacks uh against french institutions
french symbols
in france and outside of france as we
signed jeddah yesterday as well
have been made so right now france has
become through the
the free speech debate and the challenge
situation
a major focal point again for extremist
circles
and this is probably inciting the recent
attacks
the lockdown conditions in the country
right now do they make
terrorist attacks easier and and how do
they affect the police investigation
well the the police investigation isn't
the investigation
per se is not that much affected however
where
it does limit the resources that can be
deployed on the streets and it also
limits the resources
in terms of intelligence gathering
information gathering so
these create issues however right now
with the lockdown
it does reduce the possibility of attack
simply by reducing the number of targets
but as we saw in march
late march this year it doesn't prevent
attacks per se but the probability of
having an attack
is reduced simply by the reducing the
number of targets yon san pierre
counterterrorism advisor security expert
mosicon here in berlin thanks so very
much for those insights
thank you
you